27 червня. Кременчук. Росія вдарила ракетами по торговому центру "Амстор".
У приміщенні перебувала понад тисяча цивільних.
Загинула 21 особа.
14 липня. Вінниця. Три російські ракети впали посеред міста
і влучили в Будинок офіцерів і торговий центр "Ювілейний".
Загинуло 27 людей, серед яких і діти.
Найбільша небезпека для цивільного населення -
це зараз артилерія або ракетні удари.
Якщо в прифронтових регіонах - то це системи
реактивного залпового вогню.
Найбільша шкода - це якраз від уламкових поранень.
І взагалі, якщо подивитися, які поранення зараз бувають в Україні
серед усіх цивільних і військових, то на першому місці
уламкові поранення, осколкові.
Тож в умовах війни для українців критично необхідними
стають знання з надання першої медичної допомоги.
Передусім ідеться про те, щоб зупинити кровотечу
та відкрити прохідність дихальних шляхів.
Чому ми говоримо саме про критичні кровотечі?
По-перше, 80-85%, за різними статистиками,
займають смерті на догоспітальному рівні.
Причиною є саме кровотеча.
Коли ми говоримо саме про критичні кровотечі:
втрата свідомості нашого пораненого трапляється
за 45 секунд-півтори хвилини.
Допомогу травмованому мають надавати передусім ті люди,
які опинилися поруч. Адже через критичну кровотечу
смерть настає уже за 3-5 хвилин.
І швидка просто не встигне доїхати.
Кров звідти виходить з пульсацією, з фонтануючим виглядом.
Якщо бачимо щось таке - у нас критична кровотеча.
Друга ознака - ми бачимо травматичну ампутацію кінцівки:
немає частини ноги, немає частини руки.
Ще одна ознака - калюжа крові під пораненим
або пляма крові, розміром в долоню, яка швидко збільшується.
Діяти потрібно одразу. Якщо немає спеціальних медичних засобів
для зупинки кровотечі - потрібно затиснути поранення рукою:
притиснути судину до кісток чи м’язів і тримати так,
поки не приїде швидка.
Та в ідеалі було б завчасно придбати турнікет чи джгут
і носити його із собою.
Як працює турнікет? Який його принцип дії?
Коли ми закручуємо вороток – стропа стискається,
стискає, перетискає, великими м’язами притискає
магістральну судину до кістки, тобто артерію,
і перекриває кровообіг по кінцівці.
Турнікет можна накладати лише на кінцівку,
на 5-6 сантиметрів вище від поранення.
Я заводжу турнікет максимально високо в моєму випадку на кінцівку
- не на суглоб, не за суглоб. Під турнікетом немає зайвих предметів.
За один-два рухи я максимально туго затягую і заклеюю
нашу липучку, стропу. Після цього я беру вороток і починаю закручувати.
Я кручу не поки відчую біль, не поки зроблю два-три оберти
- я кручу, поки він крутиться.
Та головне: турнікет, джгут і бандаж мають бути оригінальними
та сертифікованими. Все інше використовувати не можна,
бо воно не врятує, а тільки нашкодить людині.
Він може бути або американський, і там теж їх дуже багато:
CAT, SOF, TNT і так далі. І може бути український.
З українських, які можна використовувати, - це лише "Січ".
А, приміром, китайські турнікети регулярно тріскаються і рвуться.
Ті самі бандажі, які накладаються на рану, вони так само є оригінальні,
є Китай, а є українські. От український найгірший,
він взагалі не працює, Китай - через раз, оригінальний - працює.
Так само з гемостатиком. Є гемостатик, який так і називається
"гемостатик" український, він працює. Є американський Quikclot,
є англійський Celox. І все решта, яке не працює.
Та є місця, де турнікет і джгут накладати не можна,
- це шия, пахви та пахова зона.
Тоді поранення треба затампонувати гемостатичним бинтом,
звичайним бинтом чи одягом пораненого.
Ми будемо тампонувати наше поранення.
Ми будемо робити такий самий тиск, просто іншими засобами.
Ми будемо заповнювати наш поранений канал бинтами
або іншими засобами, які можуть бути у нас під рукою.
Від початку повномасштабного вторгнення Росії українці
у 5-10 разів частіше почали відвідувати курси
першої медичної допомоги. Багато хто повторно.
Прильоти дійсно бувають у торгові центри, дійсно в ті місця,
де є звичайне мирне населення, де хтось може бути поранений.
І ти будеш мати знання, як це правильно зробити.
Тому що я думаю, що коли буде така ситуація, що буде багато людей
поранених, то не завжди з’явиться 10-20 швидких,
які зразу зможуть допомогти людям.
Олексій раніше вчився і працював у Німеччині.
Каже, там колись уже проходив домедичні курси.
У Німеччині я проходив курси, які пов’язані з автошколою.
Але цього явно було недостатньо.
Раніше, мабуть, у подібній ситуації я би просто стояв,
тому що для мене медицина - це щось далеке.
Я би не знав, чи треба виймати осколок чи кулю, чи ні.
А тут я знаю, як накладати вже турнікет, як це реально робити,
у яких місцях, скільки треба, як розпізнавати,
чи досягли ми результату, чи ні. Те ж саме з тампонуванням.
Це принципово нові навички.
Важливо також вміти відкривати прохідність дихальних шляхів,
якщо людина втратила свідомість чи має в роті блювотні маси і кров.
Ми кладемо одну долоню на голову нашого пораненого,
друга долоня йде під підборіддя і трошечки отак заводимо.
Наш язик кріпиться до щелепи, коли ми підіймаємо щелепу
- язик підіймається разом з нею.
Якщо все добре, ми в такому положенні можемо тримати голову
нашого пораненого, у нього будуть відкриті дихальні шляхи,
він не задихнеться.
Та головне - не вірити різним міфам про надання
першої медичної допомоги.
З приводу того, що треба швидко забирати уламки або якісь кулі.
Насправді уламок, який стирчить, або куля, яка стирчить, вона все вже
пошкодила. Вона своєю наявністю в тілі не наносить додаткової шкоди,
як правило. Тому нічого витягати, особливо якщо щось стирчить
із тулуба або з кінцівок, не треба.
Ще є міф з приводу того, що коли людина втрачає свідомість,
то їй треба висовувати язик або його приколювати булавкою кудись -
такого роду різна маячня.
Найбільш такий топ дивних міфів, які у нас існують, - це затампонувати
поранення засобами жіночої гігієни, що людину обов’язково треба
знеболити, людина може від болю померти, больовий шок,
якого не існує. І те, що треба час від часу відпускати джгут,
раз на пів години, раз на годину. Ні.
Якщо ми наклали джгут - він має знаходитися на кінцівці
до приїзду в лікарню або медиків.
Унаслідок ракетних та артилерійських обстрілів
люди можуть мати по кілька комбінованих поранень.
Тому важливо одразу розпізнати критичні і почати надавати допомогу.
Адже головна задача невідкладної медичної допомоги
- як під час війни, та і в мирному житті
- зберегти життя людини до приїзду медиків.